good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today is scp-505
object class
header
special containment procedures
scp-505
is contained in a 50 by 40 by 10 meter
room at site
scp-505's containment area is to be
sealed other than one secure airlock and
a series of pipes allowing transport of
scp-5051 to storage tanks in the event
of
scp-5051 reaching levels in which it
poses danger to containment sprayers for
sodium hydroxide are to be available
through scp-505's containment area and
the rest of site
to combat a containment breach in the
event of a spill of scp-5051
the affected areas should immediately be
covered with an absorbent material
commercial blotting paper is currently
standard for this purpose and doused
with alcohol or acetone if sodium
hydroxide is not immediately available
sodium hydroxide immersion is the method
of choice for
scp-5051 containment followed by
incineration of affected material if
practicable
there are currently instances of
scp-5051
points of secondary contamination
outside scp-505's primary containment
area containment in these areas is
variable but efforts have been made to
make the procedures as similar to those
of the primary site if possible of these
secondary contamination zones
are unable to be fully contained at this
time resulting in the spread of scp-5051
throughout the environment these sites
are to be monitored at all times and
counter-measure deployment is of the
highest priority for a complete list of
scp-5051 secondary containment sites
see document 505 14a
description
scp-505 is a model
faber castel fountain pen produced in
2001 for documentation of its
acquisition by the foundation see
addendum 505.2 it is identical in all
respects to a standard fountain pen
apart from its association with scp-5051
scp-5051 is the black ink produced by
scp-505
which exhibits the property of
self-replication
scp-5051 spreads at a variable rate
affected by the substance it comes into
contact with and the amount of scp-5051
present quantities of scp-5051 have been
shown to increase at rates between 0.5
and 540 milliliters per second standard
ink removing chemicals are able to
partially remove
scp-5051 and inhibit its spread however
sodium hydroxide is necessary to remove
scp-5051 contamination completely and is
shown to be ineffective in environments
with particularly high
scp-5051 concentrations fortunately the
growth rate of scp-5051
appears to be inversely proportional to
its quantity at high concentrations
whilst the observed effects of this are
negligible in most cases this inverse
growth phenomenon provides the only
explanation for the partial containment
of scp-5051
despite a number of cases of large-scale
environmental contamination which were
projected to otherwise lead to an
nk-class end-of-the-world scenario
whilst scp-5051
exhibits no unusual properties other
than its constant spread and partial
resistance to removal it nonetheless
poses serious difficulties for control
scp-5051 will flow across non-absorbent
surfaces and pass through porous
surfaces in an identical fashion to
normal ink all liquid or solid objects
or beings in contact with scp-5051
will be contaminated
scp-5051 will still adhere to non-porous
surfaces such as metals but newly
produced scp-5051 will constantly flow
off non-porous materials are thus
catalysts for scp-5051 spread and all
scp-5051 contamination should be covered
in porous materials such as blotting
paper for this reason it is not possible
to permanently contain
scp-5051 in a non-porous container as
said containers contents will gradually
increase in quantity leading to
increased pressure and subsequent
rupture all containers being used to
contain scp-5051
must therefore be drained periodically
to prevent a containment breach
scp-5051's effects on its environment
are identical to those of an equivalent
quantity of standard fountain pen ink
scp-5051 exposure will inevitably lead
to the death of living organisms plant
matter will be killed due to inhibition
of photosynthesis whereas animals will
be killed due to chemical poisoning in
humans and other mammals
scp-5051 contact will most likely be via
the skin where it will spread until it
reaches an orifice or a break in the
skin and subsequently enter the vascular
system through mucous membranes scp-505
will spread through the vasculature and
have catastrophic effects on all organ
systems it reaches as it continuously
replicates and is unable to be excreted
by the urinary system cause of death is
generally multiple organ failure
although in most cases affected
individuals will be terminated and
decontaminated prior to this for
containment procedures in these
instances see addendum 505 1.
scp-5051 also has an increased rate of
spread through non-viscous fluids such
as water as would be expected of normal
ink any contamination of the water table
with scp-5051
must be prevented at all costs due to
the potential for an nk-class
end-of-the-world scenario it is unknown
whether
scp-5051's aforementioned property of an
inversely proportional rate of spread
will manifest in fluids as
experimentation with such high
quantities of scp-5051
is strictly forbidden thus any
environmental scp-5051 contamination in
water sources must be met with immediate
damming and drainage into storage tanks
of all affected areas
addendum 505 1
procedures for dealing with scp-5051
contamination in humans
administration of multiple
dose-activated charcoal has been shown
to slow the progress of scp-5051
contamination in humans but is unable to
halt the process
the only known methods of treatment for
scp-5051 contamination in humans are by
the immediate excision of the affected
area or continuous application of
ethanol to an affected skin region
topical ethanol treatment will not
prevent the affected individual from
transmitting scp-5051
to other surfaces and is thus highly
discouraged except in the cases of
essential personnel in which case
containment procedures must be observed
as in all other sites of secondary
scp-5051 contamination in theory
excision or amputation of affected areas
would be the gold standard for treatment
but contamination of surgical
instruments and personnel remains a
problem therefore all cases of scp-5051
contamination in humans other than
essential personnel should be dealt with
by termination followed by standard
procedure of sodium hydroxide immersion
and incineration of the remains
addendum 505 2
scp-505 retrieval history
scp-505 was acquired by the foundation
from the town
in oman when the town in question was
quarantined by the omani government due
to reports of a black fluid beginning to
seep out from the town's post office and
causing the deaths of a number of its
inhabitants fortuitously the arid and
remote location of the incident
prevented wide-scale environmental
contamination of scp-5051
the foundation retrieved scp-5051 with
casualties no other anomalous properties
of the town's post office or the town
itself were detected and it was deemed
necessary to terminate civilian
inhabitants of who were deemed likely to
be contaminated the incident was
reported as a non-extra-normal chemical
spill
okay i know before you say anything
this article is very outdated this is
clearly not a ketter class anomaly but i
need to present it as what the article
says
we can all have a little discussion now
as to what it should be classified as
anyway this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye for now
i would like to give a special thank you
to
joss travolca
or in pace
alla treon
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
j k
signar
your local fishman
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nath decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
hms lily
the almighty fish
scio dio demnatus
eric corbin
longinus
the morrigan
carrie male ashmuy
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you